so i just
i just
waved my daughter goodbye again
and i thought it would be easier the
second time
brook shields in tears as she sends her
eldest daughter rowan off to college
again
oh it's so hard i miss her already
seems like heading back to school isn't
exciting for everybody as brooke gets
vulnerable about saying her goodbyes
she's already been away and she's been
with me all summer but
i'm not making the drive with her
she's driving with her dad
um but she's taking my car which is my
car
as my graduation present car and so
she's going to be driving that and
i said it was just too
painful i don't think i could go through
the driving away from campus again
nineteen-year-old rowan is starting her
sophomore year at wake forest university
in north carolina and brooke admits the
first time she took her to school as a
freshman was also a challenge every day
there's a new challenge
and judging from this clip of brook
crying in the passenger seat while
driving away from campus we get why she
called this the saddest drive away from
anywhere
worst thing i've ever experienced in my
life
it gets easier it gets easier
but the younger one i'd like to send
well kelly doesn't show up
brooke shares daughters rowan and 16
year old greer with husband chris
hinchey we have a feeling the actress
isn't ready for an empty nest just yet
since she's taking this one pretty hard
oh it's so hard i miss her already
our babies
this is what you want you raise them so
that they
save you
rowan is away at school studying
broadcast journalism and e.t put her
skills to the test back in may when she
interviewed her famous mom you've grown
up in the eye of the public and the
media do you have any advice for me and
greer moving forward in our life as we
do venture into
the business world and i mean for me
journalism you know what i always say i
always say
make sure that you find a vocation that
you absolutely love
and do it the hardest work the hardest
at it mama knows best and when it comes
to fashion brooke definitely knows a
thing or two so it only made sense that
rowan wore her mom's vintage red carpet
gown to her prom i mean i felt confident
when i wore your golden globe dress to
my prom so how do you feel about me
wearing your clothes
it was so emotional i i wore that dress
when i was nominated for a golden globe
and you looked
better than i could have ever hit me
like very well i was like
yeah we love seeing this strong
mother-daughter bond and if you relate
to brooke's struggle with your little
one going away to college she wants you
to know you're not alone
so
if there's anybody else going through
this
we're all in it together
[Music]